it's like the meryl streep stamp of
approval
i'll do anything
[Music]
first up the fantastic merrell streep is
like an onion and we just love peeling
back her layers because cnn reports that
meryl shocked her don't look up co-star
jennifer lawrence and the rest of the
world when she revealed she was watching
the real housewives of beverly hills oh
meryl now jayla herself we have known um
is a very loyal fan
of reality television and michelle obama
eddie redmayne michael rappaport rihanna
all these people have fessed up to this
is their happy place
and
meryl streep is joining that list too
kyle is there anything you watch to just
get out of inspo mode and escape well
say i don't i don't watch
this particular show but knowing that
merrell watches it
if by watching it i become more like
meryl streep sure
i will begin watching yes
it's like the meryl streep stamp of
approval
i'll do anything
next we're going to talk about another
phenomenal woman showrunner
extraordinaire shonda rhimes another
woman who i could see
leading the pack
every time she sneezes and creates
another great hit scandal how to get
away with murder grey's anatomy now
going into its eighteenth season not to
mention bridgette come on we started on
netflix and showed everybody what time
it is with her very first show becoming
the most successful show
have had thus far i think squid game
might have beaten it
just
um but i really love this because she
told people
that she may be a powerhouse but there's
one title that she fully rejects and
it's girl boss she says it's total bs
she doesn't like throwing a bunch of
women into a cheap catch phrase and she
argues don't do this
men don't have to deal with it um and
it's so true it's like there's no like
boy boss like dan what do you think of
that sort of attitudinal you gotta be
this to be successful i mean i
understand where it came from it came
from women's empowerment and after
spending time with my little nieces over
the holidays i understand sometimes
girls don't realize that they can be
anything and so the idea of like telling
them they can be a boss the sentiment's
there but really this phrase has reached
its shelf life we don't need to qualify
women that you can be a boss and and i
agree with shonda well guess what i'm
very excited about this first story um
because
nobody does it like cardi b she's a
beautiful unicorn of a woman and people
report
that cardi says she really wants a new
tattoo of her baby's name
and she wants it on her face
right on her jawline
cardian rapper offset had a son in
september and they have yet to share his
name and this is certainly one way to
present it out into the world raw
thoughts okay i love the sentiment of
getting a tattoo with you that's sweet
cardi
now i can't get behind a face tattoo i
just can't do it
because here's the deal if you get a
tattoo of somebody's name don't you want
to look at it and see it but the only
way you could see this one is if you
looked in the mirror and then it'd be
backwards that's not going to work dear
that's just not going to work true plus
if you get like a name on a jawline as
you get older it's sort of so if you get
like right if you get like care in here
it's going to be current
that's not cute that does worry me
[Applause]
any 100 reports that a writer named
flora gill recently tweeted this fact
the main characters in season one of
golden girls are
actually
younger than the current characters on
and just like that whoa they're only
younger by about a year so we're talking
character ages not actor ages but both
shows are supposed to be about women in
their mid 50s and check out this side by
side i mean this is a real i think kind
of you know math aside society moment of
what we thought women in their 50s
looked like in the 1980s versus what we
think women in their 50s look like in
whatever that heck this time is called
absolutely
um
so i mean thoughts well it's just
fascinating how we depict them right
they and golden girls they were they
were sort of gray hair they were all
single they're all living together and
now they're you know getting it
[Music]
you